chapter 18 of the Mandalorian features
dinjarin using the darksaber once again
but he still hasn't fully mastered the
strange weapon but his failure to wield
it competently is more complicated than
you might think the idea of a black
lightsaber sure sounds like something
that would live in a teenage Star Wars
fan Sketchbook and yet it's Canon and
becoming ever more important to the
franchise since being introduced in Star
Wars the Clone Wars the darksaber has
popped up in both Rebels and the
Mandalorian it's an ancient weapon with
a rich history tied to both the Jedi and
Mandalore and now it rests safely and
the capable hands of din jarin or well
mostly capable despite training
intensely with the blade in the book of
Boba Fett din still struggles with it in
the Mandalorian chapter 18. his form is
awkward and he seems to be fighting
against the darksaber as much as he's
fighting with it the darksaber was
forged by an ancient Mandalorian Jedi
named tar Vizsla after his death it was
stolen from the Jedi Temple by his clan
and since then it's been passed down
traditionally the weapon is won in
combat but earning it doesn't guarantee
you'll be able to wield it as din finds
out like all lightsabers the darksaber
is designed to tightly Focus energy from
from the crystal at its core Canon jarus
gives Sabine Wren some very useful
advice in Star Wars Rebels you're not
fighting with a simple blade as much as
you are directing a current of power
like Dan Sabine struggles at first to
control the energy of the blade Canyon
blames this on her inner turmoil saying
that her thoughts and feelings are also
channeled through the weapon when she
begins to master it he says that it's
because she's connecting to the blade
the armorer Tells din something similar
in the book of Boba Fett when he's
training with the dark saber he says
that each swing makes it heavier and she
says it's because he's fighting against
the blade according to her his lack of
dexterity is a result of a lack of focus
in other words Dan has a mental block
when it comes to the darksaber which is
clearly still in place in the
Mandalorian season 3. Ramsay is too
concerned with redeeming himself in the
eyes of his people or maybe it's his
paternal feelings for grogu that are
throwing him off whatever the cause the
effects are clear still there is hope
just as Sabine previzla and bocatan all
came to master the dark saber so to
condemn the main issue is probably just
at his priorities are elsewhere at the
moment why is the dark saber so much
more challenging to master than a
regular lightsaber well for starters
that might not actually be true most of
the lightsaber training we've seen in
Star Wars involves Force sensitive
characters who have a natural advantage
in wielding the iconic weapons the
darksaber is more often used by
mandalorians who have no natural force
Power as such they have to adapt to a
tool that was not designed with them in
mind even still the darksaber seems more
challenging to control Jedi younglings
have better dexterity with their blades
than DIN and there are numerous
instances across the franchise of
lightsabers being used by characters who
aren't Force sensitive why is the
darksaber in particular so difficult
there are a few possible explanations
for one it's a much older design than
the other lightsabers we see in Star
Wars so it's possible that its energy is
less restrained there's precedent for
this as kylo Ren's lightsaber also uses
unstable power to yield a more forceful
weapon the darksaber is also a fully
unique model so there could be some
secret Mandalorian features that make it
different to wield it's hard to say for
sure because we've never seen a
character who isn't Force sensitive
trained this much with a regular
lightsaber when Canyon instructs to
being in Rebels he seems to know what
she's experiencing with darksaber
despite not being familiar with it
himself maybe Jedi are simply better
prepared to connect with such a weapon
or maybe they have a built-in connection
since they construct their own
lightsabers as younglings
[Music]
foreign